احمد هزيم واشنطن يحكى فيها عن جهوزيه
اوكرانيه وعن تفاؤل ولكن حذر اطلعنا على
التفاصيل
نعم سلمى الولايات المتحده او المسؤولين
الامريكيين كما يذكرون انهم قدموا
لاوكرانيا ما تحتاجه من اجل شن هذا الهجوم
المضال وانهم زودوها
يمكنها من النجاح في هذه العمليه سواء من
العده والعتاد او حتى من التدريب والحديث
هنا ابعد مسؤولين امريكيين نقلت عنهم
صحيفه نيويورك بانهم يعتقدون بان العمليه
هناك مؤشرات تؤدي الى تقييم لامريكي بين
العمليه ربما تكون قد بدات خصوصا ولا
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه كما ذكرت
تقرير الصحيفه رصد نشاط كثيف للمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه وراجمت الصواريخ على طول
الجبهه الشرقيه وتحرك ايضا
لجحاف كبيره من القوات الاوكرانيه في
اعمده طويله حسب ما ذكر التقرير ما يعني
ان القوات التي تم تجهيزها وتدريبها من
قبل حلف شمال الاطلسي قد دخلت المعركه
بالفعل وهذا هو ما الى التقييم الذي ذكرته
او ذكره المسؤولون ونقلت عنه الصحيفه نقلت
عنهم الصحيفه من ان هذا هو بدء الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني هذا من جانب من جانب اخر
سمعنا لتصريحات كل من وزير الدفاع ورئيس
هيئه الاركان والذي عبر عنه ثقه لديهما
بالقدرات الاوكرانيه على شن هذه العمليه
وشن هذا الهجوم المضاد لكن هذه القره وهذا
التفاؤل هو حذرهم يعلمون بان الخصم
الموجود على ارض المعركه وخصم دوله كبيره
مثل روسيا لديها ايضا عتادها وقوتها
الخاصه بها وان على الجانب الاوكراني ان
يعمل على
تقنين مساله استخدام ما لديه من اسلحه زود
بها من قبل الدول الحليفه خصوصا الولايات
المتحده والدول في الاتحاد الاوروبي
استخدامها بشكل فعال لكن
المساله العامه او الشعور العام هنا لدى
المسؤوليه الامريكيين الذين يصرحون به
علنا هو انهم متفائلون من قد ره اوكرانيا
على القيام بهذه العمليه لكن هذا التفاؤل
مشروب بالحذر شكرا لك احمد هذه من